so i'm concerned only about the future
i'm concerned about the past only as it
affects the future so it's great we're
talking about subpoenas from what
happened
what i care about
is january 6 2025.
[Applause]
and as you know because you wrote me a
nice email after i did a piece a few
weeks ago about what i thought was going
to happen the slow-moving coup which
i've been talking about since before
trump was even elected
and if i could just review basically i
said that you know he thought
last time that all the republicans would
fall in line with what he wanted and do
his bidding and they didn't
some had integrity and what he's been
doing since
is replacing those people there's a
purge going on behind the scenes so next
time when he calls them up and says i
hope you can find me a few votes
they're going to say how many he's going
to have his stooges in place that was
what you wrote me about a lot of people
did i think it's going to happen i think
you guys the democrats are going to lose
big in 2022 which is going to make it
worse there will be more state
legislatures that can do that kind of
monkeying behind the scenes to put the
people in place who will do trump's
bidding
i think trump is going to declare for
office i think he's going to get the
nomination i think the rallies are going
to start people are going to be
it's going to get very violent out there
my question is what are we doing about
the next time the election happens say
trump loses doesn't matter whether he if
he loses he's going to say he won we
know that there's no doubt he's going to
say i won and this time
he's not going to go away so easily come
january 20th 2025.
what are we doing about that when he
is insisting that he is the president
whether he won or not and there are
people who are helping him with it well
i'm in complete agreement with
with the alarm
that you express and you feel about this
because i think what donald trump took
away from the failed insurrection is
that uh if he couldn't find uh 11 000
votes in georgia couldn't find a corrupt
elections official to give him those
votes he's determined that next time
he'll have someone in that position who
will
and basically it's a two-pronged
strategy they're trying to
disenfranchise people of color around
the country so that they can win and if
they lose
they want to be positioned to overturn
the result where i would disagree with
um your your forecast i hope and pray is
we cannot lose the house we must hold
the house if kevin mccarthy had been
speaker in 2020 if we'd lost a few more
seats in the 2020 election in the house
he would have overturned the result in
the house he will do whatever donald
trump tells him to do someone like that
can never be allowed to go near the
speaker's office
you